listening to this open house so we are
almost
towards the end uh so we will start the
Q a session soon so only I want to touch
upon a few of the FAQs uh that were
already raised uh by uh by from your
site actually so most of the FAQs were
uh addressed by Dr mitali as well as Dr
pankaj like what is the program about
and what is the what are the eligibility
criteria so few things I would like to
mention uh like what are the career
prospects after completing the program
that has been already emphasized a lot
in the slides given by Dr pankaj as well
as by Dr bahid uh what what is the
selection criteria so one has to fulfill
the minimum eligibility criteria and
then depending upon the applications
there will be an internal shortlisting
done and uh again depending upon the
applications there can be an interview
or an interaction session with you uh
that will happen after the deadline that
means after August 31st and then how
much time will be given for the payment
so after you get the offer letter so you
will be given uh three to four days of
time to uh do the payment for the uh for
the program
um the duration of the immersion period
is maximum of 15 days
and are there any scholarships or
financial aids yes so 15 of the diploma
sets will be selected for a discount by
the industry partners and each search
selected diploma participant will be
getting 30 discount on their total fees
um other than that uh regarding the
course content uh we will provide the
course content in the offer letter the
detailed uh course details about the uh
the content of the courses will be
provided with you in the offer letter
the fees cannot be paid in installment
but uh if you are willing to do the PG
diploma the entire diploma program so
you can pay the fees for the certificate
one now and then after completion of the
certificate one you can pay the fees for
the for the certificate to later
uh campus immersion is matched for
certificate 2 as well as for PG diploma
and it will be a maximum of 15 days
regarding the important date so we aim
to start the program in the second week
of September
uh that were the most uh that were the
frequent uh FAQs that were asked from
your site uh so we are now open for
questions from your side
people
when will be the reverse it was closed
of shortlisted candidates may I please
know
so pardon can you repeat sorry
or maybe it's best if you can type in
the chat box if you can put up your
questions then it will be easier also to
address them
hello
sir can I
yeah yeah please yeah please go ahead
you can ask can I can I ask you a
uh regarding the nomenclature the title
of the that is PG diploma in omics
Technologies
can can can you I mean can it be
converted to bioinformatics or
computational biology because it sounds
very new and uh uh like uh there are no
universities or I mean institutes
offering this kind of course
so this is what is unique about this
program and if you get to this course
then you will be a differentiator
so if the the purpose is for people to
be created in this space which is
unfortunately not there in our country
to a large scale
right so why do you want to be a part of
the same herd you have to be different
and as I flagged that there is an
opportunity space because if you do
those courses when you join these
sequencing facilities and all you have
to spend time in getting trained right
so as a result of which if this becomes
competitive then you have much more
advantage of getting a job earlier than
the people who come from routine areas
right so bioinformatics is something
which or not we learned on through lots
of courses but next Generation
sequencing technologies have lots of
nuances
in terms of the deep analysis in terms
of sample preparation so so there is
there is uh this kind of uh that's why
we created this and more importantly but
if you do the diploma you get become an
IIT jodhpur alumni so that itself right
so that's a purpose
thank you
yeah so I see some more questions in the
chat box
sorry
my Audible
yeah yeah is it deepesh yes uh sir uh is
this course capable to compare with MSC
bioinformatics student
or so who student who held already
master degree in this subject
post graduate diploma so as I as
Professor mitali mentioned so in the
future we also uh plan to offer M Tech
so once you go through this PG diploma
programs so whatever credits you earn
through this these programs they will be
accounted uh when you go for mtech in a
program later right
ASR
so I think there are uh I hope that
answers your questions deepest so I
think there are more questions in the
chat box yes
uh I think doctor uh harshita when will
the test be rest be disclosed so are you
not asking about the important dates
that Dr so charita has mentioned
results okay uh so so the deadline for
application is 31st and uh results will
be uh declared uh within the first week
of September
and program will be starting from second
of uh second week of the September
and also as we mentioned so most of the
our sessions will be running through
weekends
um
so uh we will inform the schedule also
to selected candidates
and there will also a specific
orientation before we start the program
retelling more about the content and
other important details of the program
yeah so I
how to Avail 30 disc so there is one
question how to Avail 30 scholarship
so uh as Dr shucharita mentioned so
there will be Dr Mohit from Pine he is
our partner in the program so they will
be offering 15 percent of the diploma
seats at uh scholarship and each
participant who is guiding the
scholarship will be have to pay 30 less
of the total fee right
how to Avail means basically so there
will be some internal selection so Dr
Mohit along with us will be doing that
internal selection and we will be
intimating those who are availing the
scholarship soon after when they receive
the offer letter
yeah just like adding uh they it would
be based on the performance of the
candidates the top performing candidates
will be shortlisted
yeah so okay thanks Dr Mike
certificate
he's in dollars facing uh yeah dollars
are you asking about the US dollars
so you can divide it by 80 I don't know
what is the current a conversion rate
today's rate it's about 1440 simple
conversions okay next is this
scholarship for certificate one for a
certificate one along there is no
scholarship so it will be only four who
is applying for PG diploma
yeah unfortunately uh there is no any
specific provision for uh waiving the
fees for low income
uh categories but uh as I said so if you
perform well as Dr Mohit mentioned so
there will be a 30 scholarship provided
by the industry partner
so that's yeah so the timing as we
mentioned so it will be all happening
during the weekends and when you receive
the offer letter we will also share the
uh the calendar and time schedule for
each of the classes and in the
orientation also and in all during the
orientation we will also elaborate when
the classes will be happening
and also just it can be flexible so if
you uh your instructor agrees then and
all the class agrees then it can be
scheduled also during the weekdays at
late late hours after five or six let's
say
generally it's a one hour
so it will be 90 minutes each session
will be 90 minutes
per week so I think they are asking for
per week
so one course will be 90 minutes so uh
so there will be four compulsory courses
so 90 times 4
and so it will be like in on two days
Saturdays and Sundays so you don't have
to like do everything on
CE yeah
so uh four sessions uh like two sessions
each day you can do yeah that is easier
easy to do actually
two hours each day yeah around two hours
three each day yeah
yeah for certificate one there is no uh
prerequisite and for certificate to the
participant has to complete uh some
basic courses in the topics that are
covered in certificate one
it's around 300 rupees per day maybe
hostel maybe the devotion can comment on
this so what is the cost of
accommodation can you uh are you any uh
suggestion for that devotion
usually the rooms are not uh the the
rooms are not for single use we give
them rooms for share use and including
the food and accommodation it will
amount to 450 rupees per day
yeah so the piece is very nominal
very very nominal for students okay
how many activities
so basically uh you will have a broader
exposure to different analytic
approaches like varying from
transcriptomics metagenomics epigenomics
so we will have basic as well as
Advanced Training in analyzing different
uh these time omics data types
and also how you can integrate these
different data types that will be
covered during the Advanced Training
there's a question from harshita she's
asking is there any written exam or
second round interview for shortlisted
candidates so there is a no uh such kind
of planning as of now so um so we will
have some interaction session to uh and
also the candidates has to fulfill the
minimum eligibility at least so we have
a limited seats also meaning we will not
have many seats so as a result of which
but depending on the number of people
who are showing interest we will have an
interaction but no written exam so you
don't have to worry about this is all
about Skilling from different areas you
come so so you will be a heterogeneous
group of people and we just would like
to interact with you to be able to know
that how geared you are it's it would be
like more of a mentoring and a
counseling kind of a session than
clearing in x some because there has to
be some minimum kind of understanding of
either biology or computational for you
to really get interested in these topics
and if you have also the skills to pick
it up that also we will gain by
interaction so that's the purpose
is asking can I do this course with my
PG course
sure if you are a very studious person
and would like to study on the weekends
why not it will give you in the same
time as you are doing PG also a diploma
and that's what some of our uh students
here do who are B Tech students and want
to major in two engineering courses so
that capability is immense and you can
for your better career options you can
do
but it's up to you whether you'll be
able to take the load so we've told you
it has to be 15 credits and it will be
conducted on weekends so if you are able
to take that I think it should be
encouraged you can take it
Ashok is asking uh what all uh what all
kind of NGS platforms will be introduced
in this wet lab
so uh Illumina and nanopore those are
the platforms
any more questions
uh but Mom uh the total hours per week
would be three uh three hours right
per week it will be uh so per day it
will be three hours
um staggered yeah usually staggered
about two days so uh six hours per week
in total six hours yes exactly okay
so Manish mahapatra it will be six hours
per week
we already covered this actually
without opportunities
yeah so I think there is also one
question about uh
what are what are the chances of getting
the job so yeah so we have as Dr Mohit
has elaborated very extensively that
there is whose uh scope after doing this
in various sectors
and uh I think uh 20 to 30 percent of
best performing students will definitely
get placements
there is an anonymous vacuum and a need
and
if you are all performing then uh
definitely lots of Industry so you can
for instance I can tell you that in our
country I think there are more than 400
plus Illumina installations and there
are huge number of
other Next Generation sequencing users
and then there are lots of service
providers so where will those people
come from as you can know if you are
most of your Masters or b-tech students
that such kind of courses are not
offered in the normal curricula and this
is more from the Skilling so you also if
you don't want to take the PHD
trajectory if you are in academics
because that is also a long journey this
is a faster way to get into a career
so so if you are worried people are I
Now understand also do coaching for uh
Kate and meaning jrf and srf so in in in
a better way you would actually gear up
for
much better skills which the industry
needs quite a lot even the academic
institutions which have these facilities
in place
they would need
so
any system laptop laptop would be
required because the courses or any
computer would be required because the
courses are online you would have to
get on to uh attending it right Mohit
can also comment on this Dr do you want
to comment on this I think there is no
any high-end laptop requirement it can
be some basic
yes we just need a good internet
connection browser base we have all of
these Technologies also available
through browser so they would not need
to you know install anything heavy or
there is no heavy requirement
yeah so most of the heavy analysis will
be done on servers so don't you don't
need to worry about buying any other
system
yes
okay so are there any more questions
you are always
encouraged or welcome to write emails if
you have any queries so there is an
email ID that has been mentioned in the
brochure
sir one question is from my side I am
from Pharma background I just completing
my bachelors of Pharmacy
and I learned from in my B Farm I
learned a computer drug design basic
autodoc software uh contacts after
something like so it is the
bioinformatics suitable for me
yes so definitely so this program
actually we and praise also people from
bi Pharma should come and do this
program because there will be from basic
to Advanced we are offering uh the skill
development as and as well as we have
electives scattering to specifically to
biopharma sector
because I'm only learn about
biotechnology and two semester because
it is only few so I think I
thank you Sarah
yeah welcome
arvind has asked is there any
requirement for coding Linux language
knowledge required
yeah Dr Mohit do you want to address
this
no I think we would want to we want you
to learn the application of uh different
types of python and R languages and we
will start with the basics that what
biologists or by informaticians or
people who are you know expecting to
analyze NGS data would be requiring to
do so this will not be like a typical
development or developer type of course
but it will be more of application kind
of a course so the expectation is not
for you to write different types of like
100 lines of codes or thousand lines of
course but to understand code so I think
that we will cover from the beginning
beginner level so not no such knowledge
is required at this moment
so if there are no further questions I
would request you all to go ahead and
get yourself registered for the program
uh as soon as your application comes in
and we do the short listing we will be
having the orientation for this program
and then uh you will get the offer
letters with the requirement for the
program fees that needs to be paid
and then uh we plan to start this
program at the earliest
so
um
if you have any further questions you
can directly write us you already have
uh the office ID uh through which you
have received been receiving emails you
can directly write to us or the email ID
that has been provided in the brochure
of this program
uh is there anything else you would like
to mention
go to pankaj
yeah I think that's all I think there
are two more queries quick maybe quickly
address them so class recordings yes it
will be provided so don't worry about
all the materials Learning Materials
will be provided
and regarding the bat live I think there
is okay yeah we will definitely be doing
this kind of training in NGS as
mentioned yeah
okay
so I think
uh
thank you for uh your attention yeah so
thank you so much uh for attending and I
can assure you I've been in this area
for the last 22 years so when I started
the career uh there was molecular
biology and venkateshwara college used
to run a very good program on Next
Generation meaning on diploma after
um after graduation one year diploma
postgraduate diploma in molecular
biology now and they were very
exceptional people who could join the
first generation of sequencing
Technologies and they worked with me for
many years I've been in I was a
scientist at The Institute of genomics
and integrative biology and I've seen
the field grow so now the time has come
for the same kind of a diploma in the
Next Generation uh space so so I really
am positive that uh you if you join this
program there would be a a real uh
competitive CV you will get which will
allow you to have an edge if you want to
start an early career after your
Master's education
so so we look forward to uh to your uh
joining and that's why we organize this
open house because
um we were getting certain queries and
we thought that if we talked to you
about the program maybe you might get a
better Clarity and hopefully we've been
able to at least get that across to you
so and you can always write and we will
be there to address your queries and do
forward it to your friends other friends
who might also want to kind of get into
this we will be holding another open
house on uh Saturday next Saturday so if
there are friends you know who would
want to know about this and who would
who would have questions then please do
let them know thanks so much
thank you Mom
thank you everyone thank you everyone